so you need to do a bit of rearranging
to get this right first okay because
it's in a y equals 4 which is fine okay
but not the easiest one to work out the
domain okay so let's just rearrange a
little bit I'm going to Y minus 1 now
just look at this for a second with me
just look up at this point if I want all
of the modifications and changes and
alterations to Y with the Y okay you
know okay I have 2/3 here okay now well
what have you probably have written okay
next line why I'm three minus PI on six
that's fine that's correct okay
however I think it's key more useful to
write it like this and I wonder if you
can see why
it's the heat okay now why is it useful
well if you've actually finished
graphing it right
what is there's a vertical shift
happening here right what is the
distance of the vertical shift
how far is it gone it's it's gone this
distance hasn't it
okay so if you were to write Y on three
- planet six that actually obscures the
fact that how far it goes is actually
Pilar - right the Y is being changed
plan to ever division by three happens
later okay so I'm gonna leave it like
that and now I'm gonna work out anything
okay don't mean X minus one that's
between our standard boundaries okay so
you add one to everything and you're
between zero and two oh good so now I've
gone to the right hand side that's not
got range this is a little trickier okay
so Y minus PI 2 all divided by 3 that's
going to be between our normal
boundaries okay so the first thing I do
is multiply through by three
and now oh I'd pilots you to everything
right so what am i upper and lower
boundaries there by going from this plus
PI to minus 5 and these three and a half
pi plus pi is to five ok so now I have
my boundary set out right so on the
basis of that domain and range even if
you want us to like a domain and range
um you have to work out the endpoints if
you're gonna graph this thing anyway
right see you might as well so ever on
the right-hand side okay so yes question
but I'm pretty sure it's mine okay so
now I've got all the important points
right I've got 0 1 & 2 you do need that
middle thing if you don't label it
you're put in reflection has to line up
with the middle okay otherwise you guys
wrong now I'm from minus PI to PI ok now
I was just talking about the point of
inflection all right now even though
it's not a calculus question and they're
not gonna say they might say find it for
infection and so on right
I still need to know whereabouts it
should go right but because it's sine
inverse graph or even a closed you miss
grounds right I'm gonna know it's
exactly in the middle so where is the
middle hon - exactly right you can see
that there right between here and here
halfway on - okay so the three points I
need to pass through are the endpoints
because if you're like me if you don't
want that in now you just draw it you're
almost certainly which is why you don't
diagnose a pencil now having drawn it
you can see now I'm also missing another
piece of information what needs to get
put on you what's missing yeah there's a
there's an intersection here okay now
I've drawn it actually pretty well so it
actually looks like it's on there but
you know if it wasn't such a nice value
because this is 1 and this is 2 right
how do we go about what yeah the
x-intercept yeah he is he's my equation
right
so I'm gonna let Y cool so thank yous me
that should be equal to zero you can see
when I move this across and divide I'm
going to get minus PI on six over there
right so now if I take sine of both
sides what do I get on the right hand
side minus 1/2 1 and that does look like
it's pretty much between zero one set up
sure happy I mean what would I have to
do by the way if I wanted to say this
would be the other way around if I were
to flip it how would I change this yeah
there just be 101 minus X would be minus
X minus one anyway but you can see you
know either that or it could be in terms
of a causing that it doesn't matter okay
but I think the important thing to get
is the calculation of the domain and
range that's the biggest help okay and
then make sure if you end up with any
intercepts you gotta work them out okay